in an interview with the hill Democratic
presidential candidate and avowed
socialist Bernie Sanders said China had
done more to address extreme poverty
than any country in history listen but
what we have to say about China in
fairness to China and its leadership is
if I'm not mistaken they have made more
progress in addressing extreme poverty
than any country in the history of
civilization okay so they've done a lot
of things to their people he's right
according to the World Bank the number
of poor in China went from 880 million
in 1981 to less than 10 million but I
wonder how they did that well the
Chinese socialists killed millions of
poor people so there's that dead people
aren't poor just dead they called that
the Great Leap Forward
and after that they used the tool that
Bernie despises capitalism I wish there
was a visual metaphor for Bernie's
argument I don't know why anyway it was
only after China rigorously adopted
free-market principles private ownership
decentralization that they transformed
their economy from a house of horrors to
something much more humane the stuff
that saved a billion lives in China
maybe the things Bernie thinks has
harmed our country the less of those who
scream about inequality embrace ideas
that create only more inequality by
replacing equal opportunity with equal
outcome you end up with two classes the
poor and the powerful which happened in
China and seems to be happening in San
Fran LA and Baltimore to of course China
went whole communist resulting in mass
murder religious persecution forced
abortion of female babies and famine the
number of dead in China under Mao has to
be counted in the tens of millions so
yeah praise is an order for China
finally coming around to abandoning bad
ideas maybe Bernie should do the same
Danny you were very very excited about
this topic today because it bothered you
what he said I listen to your monologue
and I look at the things I wrote down
and I think hmm
I've might have been sitting next to you
for many years I don't feel like I have
too much other things to add when Bernie
Sanders says China has done a lot for us
people I thought no it's - yeah it's
people and the idea is that they put in
the sort of quasi capitalism what's
happened is that they've created this
middle class yeah it's a huge middle
class and we should want to sell them a
lot of things because they have money to
buy but one of the things that's
upsetting to them is that there's no
rule of law and they don't have private
property rights so then what do you have
happen they would like to take their
capital and move it someplace else where
do you think they want to put it right
you know let's put in the United States
because it's safe and you have rule of
law and I mean I would love to have
somebody in the United States actually
stand up for the human rights problems
like Bernie Sanders doesn't talk about
that at all in the interview and I think
that he's he agrees with President Trump
on being tough on China regarding trade
yeah but other than that I don't see how
the Democrats are actually
differentiating themselves from
President Trump at all on China the
president however has started remember
at the State of the Union What did he
say the United States will never be a
socialist country and that was his
opening salvo to differentiate himself
against the Democrats and the Democrats
don't seem to be doing anything to stop
that mm-hmm it seems like they're just
moving leftward wan leftward and
leftward and leftward
well that's not even a question I
admitted because otherwise would be very
Chinese in authority of you but I must
say that I think Bernie is speaking
against the heavy-handed use of tariffs
which is driving the whole economy to
the verge of recession and damaging the
Chinese economy so what he's saying is
there should be there is an opportunity
I think he's saying for closer ties
between the US and China that we don't
have to somehow demonize them as all
evil and terrible and if it's not jpowel
the federal reserve then it's you know
the Chinese President as our enemy I
think he's trying to get out of that
mindset but I thought you're exactly
right when you talked about how China
has made progress I mean to my mind
maybe you're even giving too much credit
to the Chinese
government because I think it's after
mal after the Revolution after the
re-education camps and the torture and
the murder that then you see the Chinese
people start to rise up with the
opportunity to employ free market ideas
like property like investment bringing
in American companies but to me it's
still the case and you can see it from
you know but the news we have today
about Hong Kong and about the protests
you can see it in terms of no Free Press
you can see it and understand it in
terms of repression how they treat the
Muslim minority there in China that the
Chinese government is still to me
heavy-handed and authoritarian yeah so I
would give them credit for you know I
think what it's a three-quarters of the
reduction in global poverty over the
last 20 years has been in China right
Mendes but I think Bernie is speaking
less about that actually than he is
about hey why can't we work with China
instead of and this is speaks to Dana's
point instead of using these tariffs in
a way that is not to our advantage
hurting our economy it's hurting German
Germany's economy it's hurting China's
economy alright just I would love to see
Bernie Sanders get on an airplane and
make that speech in Hong Kong because
come on if they continue to prove to
praise these communist countries if he
wasn't praising China he was praising
Venezuela if he wasn't praising to
Venezuela he was praising Russia he's
not he's a leader of the Democratic
Party he's not even in the Democratic
Party he's a Democratic Socialist and
but he has got to understand the
difference between what he's doing at
Donald Trump and everybody else is doing
is showing the positive things of
capitalism yes it can be better but it
is lifted more people up out of poverty
provided more wealth in the history of
the world than anything else and yet he
can't bring himself to actually giving
capitalism the credit it deserves what
do you think Emily you hate capitalism I
just like Bernie is such a farce you
guys at a time when Hong Kong is being
squashed and he comes on the interview
and he says you have to make a very
strong statement for democracy and for
human rights and of course this
administration isn't and then of course
though we've heard nothing about the
Leaguer concentration camps
I wonder under under Bernie's administer
would he recognize Taiwan as a country
would he there's there's so much that he
has failed to address that China
represents he ignored or kind of shot
down the existential threat question as
well
I mean why aren't we hearing from him
his position on China's stated purpose
of nuclear and trade power on their
random presence on the Arctic Circle
Council you know every five years that
president of China gives a political
report right and in 2017 President
Jinping did and thirty times he said
China will be a global power he stressed
that he they wanted to improve their
combat capability or whatever and he
also said we will never swallow the
bitter fruit of downgrading our
interests for a purpose of someone
else's benefit so for Bernie to go out
there publicly and say they are not a
threat to us or that they won't put
themselves first and ignore all the
other human rights violations is again
it's such a joke to me mm-hmm well I
think we pounded that segment into the
ground thank you thank you